it is one of the most beautiful but
often overlooked places
in the united states perhaps not for
much longer
it's awesome it is awesome this is
superintendent lizzie watts
third tour at new river gorge and based
on what just happened
it's hard to imagine it's not her
favorite are you like why hasn't it been
named a national park
until now or are you just happy that it
actually did happen
a little both just a day's drive from
half the u.s population
the new is actually very old estimated
to be the second
oldest river in the world the terrain is
long
skinny and wild people have been playing
in this river for thousands and
thousands of years
and left parts of their world
first explored and settled by native
americans then fought over in the civil
war
the new and its surrounding gorge have
become a recreation
destination but rewind 100 years
and things looked a lot different the
rumor is there were 13 different honky
tonks and bordellos and
in the red light district it looked like
a little vegas
it was a little vegan it was a little
vegas people come from all around
to come to thurman and now they come for
entertainment just a different kind a
different kind of time that we hope yes
jerry cook runs ace adventure resort and
is the man responsible perhaps more than
anyone else for shepherding the gorgeous
transformation
from mining hub to an oasis for outdoor
activities
at one point this was coal central
yeah more coal came through here in the
1910s and 20s than
the whole line combined from richmond to
chicago
downtown thurman today is population
five
it's the smallest town in west virginia
has its own mayor
it's essentially a ghost town yes ghost
coal towns like thurman once fueled the
industrial revolution
the trains still run through but the
mining does not
in its place some of the best rafting
runs
in the world what is it about this river
it like gets in your veins and it's a
place that doesn't depend on snowpack so
you're getting
a long season here yeah we get a really
long season like we'll start
in march and we'll go through the end of
october even trips into november
sometimes
because it's really just kind of rain
water dependent brian baker is a guide
with ace
who's been taking people down the new
for 19
seasons i was told they wouldn't do this
story unless
i offered to be abused on the water
not abused i facilitate experiences that
sounds better
yeah than abuse for sure but we're
talking about class
four and five or no sure that's a lot
it's legit it's good stuff
okay good so we're heading where down to
the new river
with bryant we approached fayette
station if i fall out
head away from the rocks correct you're
going to head to the left the renowned
rapid that sits just below west
virginia's most famous landmark
the new river gorge bridge they ready
all right let's go go forward
we'll let the water take it from here
all right stop good
nice and forward again
and stop beautiful yeah
nice how's that good good stuff take a
look back
there are in total 53 miles of undammed
white water along the new
to go along with climbing biking and
even one day a year base jumping
the only national park where you can
legally do that
this park also holds another unique
distinction
this is now the only park national park
in the lower 48 with a dual designation
that allows hunting why
because it's a traditional use the
southern appalachians are a very unique
culture
and these mountains are very unique but
people have been hunting here forever
so when they were trying to figure out
what we really should be when we grew up
allowing people to can keep those
traditional uses and hunting's one of
them was really important
are you worried that the increased
attention is going to bring
too many visitors and too many new
issues
to the park am i worried do i have a
little bit of fear i have to admit i do
but i think the reality is we'll figure
it out
here's one one good thing about the
pandemic people who ordinarily wouldn't
be outside especially some of the
younger generation
have come outside last summer and now
this spring
cobot has nothing good to say but what
it has done is it's taught a whole new
generation
to come play in the outdoors you know to
feel the water to go on a rafting trip
to take a hike
just to sit by the river we've seen that
that's a great change
and they'll always keep playing in the
outdoors i believe that now
did you see me dominate the river
earlier
[Laughter]
you know what jeff i would have been
more impressed if i had seen you climb
that
rock face i've done that too but i'll do
it again
lizzy watts thank you very much i mean
she is she is tremendous and is it bad
that i still get goosebumps hearing take
me home country roads
i've heard it 6 000 times in my life it
is the scenery there is beautiful
those rapids looked amazing i'm jealous
i've never done that i would love to do
that
it's worth it again a days drive from
half the u.s population
wow amazing stuff